[Music]
my name is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
the movie Logan has very tightly
constructed and and surprisingly
complete symbolic pattern it's written
as the basic ascent of a mountain the
kind of ascent you find in religious
stories all the time the movie is so
densely structured that up I won't even
try to unpack all the implications of
how it's set up
but hopefully I can give you all a basic
line to follow and trying to interpret
the details the opening of the movie
shows a kind of fallen world the world
of the limit we could call it in a very
real way the movie begins at the bottom
of the world and that's represented as
the southern border so in my video on
guardians of the galaxy I discussed the
notion of the hero as the one who stands
on the border and in many ways acts as a
kind of guard to defend it but in an
almost paradoxical way at the same time
the hero is a hybrid and straddles the
border himself I mean if you haven't
seen it yet watching that video of
guardians of the galaxy will help you
see the extent of what I'm discussing so
Logan himself is a border crosser he
moves from one side of the border to the
next every every morning and then in the
evening because he he works in the
United States and then he returns to
Mexico where he's hiding
and so all the images line up the desert
the fence on the border the the poor but
also we also see these decadent rich
people and mostly there is this image of
death Logan is dying
his body is falling apart he's not
healing anymore as it as he usually does
because of his mutant powers and his
incapacity to pull his body together is
shown as a form of dissipation of
impotence it's a it also are giving in
to his passions as well as a kind of
selfish self-absorption this is all
brought together at the very beginning
of the movie we're waking up from this
drunken stupor he tries to defend his
rented limo from a band of thugs now the
car is a proxy for the body or the house
it's the container I mean it doesn't
really matter at which level you see it
what's important is in the fact that he
can't stop it from being damaged
you know his claws come out slowly to
show his impotence but then he also
completely goes berserk and then
slaughters all the thugs in gruesome
ways all of this is a very powerful
image of this loss of cohesion it is
that loss of control which happens at
the edge another image of this attempt
to bring together to protect or to
that's a to hold on to the vehicle of
life is in the fact that Logan's sole
remaining purpose seems to be to get
enough money to get an ark like Noah get
a boat by which he can escape the chaos
and these different aspects of the edge
they lead us to a funeral in the rain so
death as I said is the frame of this
loss of cohesion and standing on the
brink of death knowing because we've
been told that he's in Phoenix and like
the bird that rises from its ashes
standing in the face of death is where
he hears the first call for
transformation the call to ascend though
he doesn't know it yet
you know he doesn't know what's
happening because he's too self-absorbed
to attend to a call for help and so here
is this angel calling him Gabriela is
her name Gabriel feminine of Gabriel and
she wants him to she wants it she wants
him to help her her save what turns out
to be his own clone a feminine child
version of himself which is in danger of
being killed and so by helping Gabriela
and this child by helping another
he is and will be helping himself so
symbolically we have now these two
Logan's the old dying Logan and the
young future Logan and her name is Laura
which is very close to Logan in terms of
of sonority now to understand the
transformation that occurs the character
of Wolverine itself plays an important
part because he's constantly related
through his name through his appearance
and through his character to a kind of
animal passion a kind of berserker rage
so the basic ascension of the mountain
motif and the whole movie can be seen as
as the difficulties and the
possibilities of taming something of
taking something out of control
something self-absorbed something dead
wild foreign drunk all these images of
chaos which line up this idea of naming
something then taming it bringing chaos
to participate to become the body or the
vehicle of logos of the world so in a
way it's a story of redemption of
creation recreation and redemption
now with the two logan's we have a
beautiful pattern because we can both
see the raw chaotic young Logan and the
little girl you know wild without
manners without self-control but also
silent at the beginning without logos
herself an image of chaos if we've ever
seen one and at the same time we have
the final result of that state the old
dying Logan she did you know drunk
cynical selfish angry sick and falling
into death even contemplating suicide
now all these images are quite
traditional and for more about this you
can check out the talk I gave called
Pentecost for the zombie apocalypse
where I explained the relationship
between animality and death in biblical
symbolism so Logan has to bring this
child which is at the same time as
future self out of the bottom of the
rolled out of a prison slavery because
you know just like the Hebrews in Egypt
remember that little girl was a slave to
those that made her he has to escape
this cyborg half-man half-machine
you know this dry technical medicated
etc etc world and bring her where bring
her to Eden now Eden is of course an
image of the center an image of the
height the the ascension from the edge
from the bottom of the world the edge or
the bottom of his person and up towards
a place of refuge so that's why they
insist that Eden is north in North
Dakota opposing it to the southern
border but at least what Wolverine has
been going going for him or at least he
he is somewhat following let's say
Jordan Peterson's advice he's trying to
save his father from the underworld and
Professor X lives in an empty falling
water cistern this is of course a very
potent image of the grave a kind of cave
shell but dried up a return to dust the
Bible we see this image when Joseph is
lowered in a cistern in an in an empty
cistern to die on his way to Egypt and
the movies pretty amazing because
professor X is really the past very
cohesively he he's four things at the
same time he's a kind of scattered
rambling vestige of the past he also
carries a great past sin you know being
responsible for killing all the mutants
he's also this powerful force of
immobilization capable of freezing
people into statues so they can no
longer move forward but at the same time
he's also this wise father encouraging
Logan and recognizing in Laura that she
is a better version of Wolverine that
needs to be encouraged and saved so
encouraging Logan to say it to help
Laura to hell
that family in trouble all of this is
pretty amazing but at the beginning
Logan wants to saves a gear but but only
he only sees the negative parts of his
father he wants to save him but he's
think he's incapable of hearing the
wisdom and that'll come gradually as the
movie progresses so alright so they're
going to eat it but then Logan finds out
that Eden comes from a comic book Eden
exists at the story level of reality and
so obviously Logan doesn't believe in
Eden
you know he's something maybe of a new
atheist with all the drunken cynicism of
a Hitchens though he still moves he
still moves coaxed by external events
and and slowly attending to the wisdom
of his father but in the act of moving
towards the heart moving towards the
center there will always be resistance
and the biggest resistance comes from
within ourselves and from our own
passions and so enter third Logan shadow
Logan the doppelganger and this Logan is
pure rage pure animal without logos he
only grunts and kills and so there's
this fight between the two Logan's to
decide about future Logan which way will
it go and so we basically got set up
something like this what is the future
will you go up towards Eden or back down
towards chaos and there's a very
powerful scene in the movie where Xavier
confesses his great sin to Logan he
realizes it he knows that he's been the
cause of a horrible thing that's been
keep that's been that's kept underground
kept secret and and then it's in fact
shadow Logan who then goes on to kill
him
so Logan is both trying to kill the
tyrannical father and save the wise
father at the same time it's a pretty
amazing setup but what is also amazing
is that the death of Xavier is the
beginning of the real movement
up the mountain Logan buries his father
and he can't speak at the funeral he his
logos is not there he can only utter the
Khaosan you know all he can say is it's
got water which sounds like it doesn't
make sense but you'll see why it does
make sense and at that moment Logan
takes on what he needs from Xavier but
he is at his lowest point and then like
in the limo scene at the beginning we
see him losing control of his car again
and then he passes out
so here the passing out is a kind of
dying the baptism one could say and he
awakens symbolically underwater you see
him looking up at these floating fish
and from then on there is this beginning
of an ascent the ascent begins as a
literal let's say ascent of logos
because the silent child begins to talk
first in a foreign language then in
English which is a powerful image of
this taming of what is foreign we're
shown the ascent you know as we see the
once again passed out Logan being lifted
up towards the sunlight in a stretcher
and there he confesses to his feud to
his future he confesses the desire to
die the difficulty of redemption but
he's moving up he's tonsured right his
beard is cut to make him look more like
himself more like the Wolverine that we
know and he starts to heal but he still
hesitates he still stumbles he hesitates
one more time and then finally he
commits themselves completely commits
himself completely he rushes up the
mountain but to go up the mountain as
many things like that at once and the
movie shows it quite powerfully in a way
that going up the mountain is a fight
but it's also a dying not the kind of
sickness and lock loss of cohesion which
which is the death at the bottom of the
mountain but it is the death of
self-sacrifice it is the cross on
Golgotha Hill and that's what happens
logan accepts
died to himself to be hung on a tree in
order to save others but all but
ultimately to save himself you know
there have been many superhero movies
recently which so show the hero you know
his hands out in the shape of a cross
but but here the symbolism is more
profound than just a simple visual
reference to the crucifixion so hung on
a tree and in sacrificing himself logan
attains the highest point of logos and
there his shadow also dies and we find
that Laura as she is Barrett burry bring
him you know where Logan could not speak
to the death of his father
Laura speaks clearly she speaks of
identity of the opportunity and the
consequence of identity she says a man
has to be what he is and it's pretty
good it's pretty effective and now we
know that Laura will cross the border
north finishing the whole set up of a
southern border of death and in northern
heavenly gate of freedom through Eden
and then above through Eden and the
cross at the same time so it's pretty
amazing of course more laterally the
image of going north is playing up with
the references to the underground
railroad railroad which which brought
slaves to Canada in order to free them
but what's also amazing is that by going
north to Canada
we conclude this basic symbolism of
procession and return this pattern and
so in the end it's a return to the
origin for if Laura was born in Mexico
Logan was born in Canada so all in all
it ends up being a very effective movie
now I have to admit there are some
strange aspects to the movie and one is
of course that it seems to participate
in this new tendency of replacing the
masculine with the feminine in a way in
this case we could see we could see that
the girl you know is the
Angella of the future and he's moving
into this potential but there's
something else going on you know if we
look at it as a larger social pattern we
see this happening in many media right
now the new Ghostbusters the new Doctor
Who a lot of the Marvel heroes in Marvel
Comics were changed into women and and
we see it very clearly in this story of
Moana the movie the Disney movie who
replaces the line of male Chiefs and
adds her pink and rather suggestive
shell on the top of the masculine column
column and I think we need to stay away
to the consequences of this rising
pattern and maybe I'll make a video
about this at some point but apart from
that I would say that in terms of
symbolism Logan Logan shows us how deep
the imagery and symbolism of
Christianity goes in our culture and
despite its gruesome violence this movie
it's it's in many ways the pattern of
the struggle that we all have you know
in US and as for the symbolism of the
mountain for those who might want to
learn about the direct parallel with
with the structure that are in the Bible
especially the the story of Moses I
would suggest to watch my video on
divine patterns in the st. Gregory of
nYSSA's life of Moses so that's it I
hope it was helpful I'll see you soon if
you enjoyed this content and our
exploration of symbolism get involved I
love to read your comments in the
comments section below please go ahead
and share this on social media to all
your friends and also please consider
supporting us financially on patreon
you'll find the link to the patreon page
in the description below